exercise is sacred to cyrita
running was the antidote to her
depression after sudden sight loss in
her twenties she feels limited Vision
limits her options I always felt like
the gym
wasn't accessible to me I think it was
just a fear within me like I won't be
able to see the machines and people
would look at me funny because I don't
use a cane or a dog like so most people
don't even realize I have sight loss at
that point in my life I didn't want
people to know I had sight loss and then
if I go to the gym and I'm from a little
about and I can't see things then people
would know
the sentiment unsurprisingly common
people with sight loss are twice as
likely to be inactive compared to the UK
average almost half surveyed said
barriers got in the way including lack
of assistance difficulty with public
transport and the inaccessibility of
some venues
if you don't know anyone with sight loss
then you're often going to think that
maybe you just don't know what someone
could do and there's a bit of fear
around what you know what people might
be able to do you don't want to maybe
say the wrong thing or do the wrong
thing so often it's just actually that
understanding of sight loss and being
able to support someone with whatever
they need
but Sports of inclusivity can go hand in
hand
I used to do basketball a lot and then
obviously since my start got worse it
got a little bit harder so Global's
giving me that extra boost and
confidence to like participate in sport
gold ball is a bit like football but
more inclusive
to level the playing field all players
are seated and wear eye shades
bells and the ball helped track sound
and the quartz lines are tactile so they
can be felt by all players when visually
impaired people become isolated it does
become very very lonely it's very very
hard to find people to talk to
especially if you don't have a visual
cues especially within the conversation
itself but then you come into a sport
excuse me that was designed specifically
for the visually impaired and you kind
of almost feel like you're home
the coach says more awareness and
funding is desperately needed and while
there's some progress it's still not
enough
Sky News in Croydon
[Applause]